do you want to know the secret to
everyone who is building a powerful and
successful business online
think about your favorite gurus online
or even your favorite brands yep they
have this too they have this one
powerful strategy in place and it's part
of the engine of their online empire
they all have an email list
if you're building a business or brand
of any size in 2020 and beyond
one of the most important business moves
you could make is spending time and
resources to build your email list i
mean think about it building your
influence on social media is rented land
you don't own instagram and here at
think marketing we want to equip you to
learn how to create thriving online
businesses without falling victim to the
algorithm changes that can happen at any
time email marketing it it's your
insurance in the unpredictable nature of
social media platforms having them
coming and going you don't know what
will happen but having email is so
important and even with these powerful
platforms email is a live and well you
know as a consumer myself i love opening
up my email and seeing valuable content
from the businesses and the brands that
i love and follow i like getting insider
information tips and strategies and
coupons and discounts those emails are
amazing an email is actually their
direct access to me
and on today's episode it's probably one
of my most favorite ones we've done so
far on the think marketing podcast so
grab a notebook and get ready because
sean sits down with number one
best-selling author and serial
entrepreneur pat flynn to dive into the
best practices of email what tools and
software you need to not only get
started but to scale and make sure that
you stick around until the end where pat
shares this one strategy for how he's
generating sales and growing his
business on autopilot
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast for growing and
scaling your business with online video
i'm heather torres and i'm sean cannell
and we're from think media and if this
is your first time listening welcome
this show is dedicated to helping you
learn how to get your content noticed
and the latest money making strategies
working right now online so whether you
want to grow your youtube channel or you
want to maximize video across all of
social media this podcast is for you
welcome back to the think marketing
podcast today we're talking all about
email marketing and the importance of
using email to grow your business to
have consistent revenue and some of the
best practices with email we're going to
be answering the question of why email
marketing and is email marketing dead
and today i'm joined by my guest and
friend pat flynn the founder of smart
passive income how's it going pat stoked
man dude i'm so excited for you and the
show because i was there when it all
started for you just congrats to you and
your team man thank you so much people
have been loving the podcast and you are
the podcast king and your content your
courses thank you have helped us uh
really launch this podcast and we're
excited because it's really just getting
started dude the world of podcasting is
just getting started i mean there's less
than one million shows out there still
so you came in at the right time good
job man i love that and uh for those
that are just meeting you you know first
of all we're so pumped that you're
coming to las vegas to grow with video
live as one of our speakers dude i'm
stoked yeah yeah not just because it's
in vegas sure i'm there to serve you
your community you've helped me out so
much just really excited to give back
and
we're gonna have some fun it's gonna be
a lot of fun um but for those of you
that are just meeting you how do you
help people and what are you all about
so quick story i was laid off in 08 from
my architecture job that was my dream
job and i survived that layoff because i
started an online business helping
people pass an architecture exam
and after that happened and i made over
six figures in a year doing that a lot
of people started asking me for help so
since then i've just been devoted to
helping others discover what things they
can offer others not trying to create
the next uber or spacex or whatever like
i want people to know that every single
person out there has the ability with
their skills experiences personality to
find people who will resonate with them
and their message to help them as you
often say impact their influence and
income and grow that online so uh i i've
just been doing this for the last decade
through podcasting blogging video now as
well as writing books and speaking all
around the world so i'm just i'm just
here to serve and and hopefully help
people make either a few extra bucks if
they need it in their life or even quit
their jobs that they hate that's why i'm
here man i love that and your content
has been amazing and you have a lot of
great uh different topics that you cover
you've got a great youtube channel
couple powerful podcasts really
successful books but today we're talking
about email marketing and the cool thing
about this topic is that it's an
essential topic probably a little
undercovered in some circles and no
matter where you're building your
influence whether it's youtube or in
podcasting or social media across the
board another friend of ours and speaker
of growth video live chalene johnson
talks about this kind of like if you're
not building your email list you're not
even building your business and you're
very vulnerable to the algorithms and
things like that but before we even get
into it why email marketing you know i
think some people could think email me
email's dead men does anyone use email
anymore for old people um yeah dude
every year there's this email is dead
kind of thing but you know what else
happens every year the social media
streams and platforms that we're on and
dedicating our time and love and sweat
into they're putting up walls between
ourselves and those who said they want
to hear from us right we see it in the
algorithms we definitely see it on
facebook and instagram and other places
where you kind of have to pay to play
and uh i think it was toby i can't
remember his last name but he's the
founder and ceo of shopify he said guys
email is the last place we have total
control over every other place is
somebody else's sandbox and when you
play in other people's sandboxes they
can make up any rules
that they want so email is still the
best way to connect directly with people
who say yes i want to hear from you
now there's still the idea of well
you're also fighting against other
people in in an inbox and of course
there's strategies related to writing
great subject lines and you know
creating content that actually wants to
be opened and that kind of thing but
when it comes down to it you still own
your list and i'll tell you i was hacked
in 2013 my website was hacked it was
down for two and a half weeks and i make
you know my website was making two to
three thousand dollars a day like that's
a lot of money that was lost no doubt so
scared that my website would be gone and
my business would be shut down forever
but i remembered
oh i have this email list i could
literally set up shop somewhere else if
i needed to so bring it on hackers don't
actually probably shouldn't say that
sure don't bring it on just i respect
you but anyway um yeah the the email
list is your business insurance yeah
it's your business insurance and it's
also an amazing way to directly
communicate with yes you to them kind of
in mass but when a person receives an
email still feels very personal and if
you're doing any sort of research if
you're starting a business and you want
to understand what are the biggest pains
and problems and struggles that my
target audience has what should i should
my course be on what videos should i
create what blog content should i write
about well
when you have an email list you don't
have to guess you just ask we're going
to talk a lot about all kinds of
strategies related to that today yeah
and we're going to jump into five
strategies but you know when i think
about email too and from learning from
friends like you and chalene um when we
started video influencers benji and i
the reason we actually launched the
channel because we knew we wanted to
write a book
and i was talking to chalene and she was
talking about how you could get on good
morning america she did or you know and
shows like i think even regis and kelly
at the time it was maybe just kelly
and that even peers of her that would
maybe launch a book for example so
whether it's a business you've launched
physical products like switch switchpod
and that you need an email list if you
want to do that successfully because yes
you can tell social but you know what
your reach will be there
and so we want to write the book youtube
secrets which today is the number one
best-selling youtube strategy book in
the world i love it i think we're up to
like 35 000 copies sold in our niche
that's pretty remarkable
and
uh what's powerful about that though is
we started the process in the journey of
creating the book but i realized from
good mentors right from watching and
listening to podcasts like this
investing myself
we put the brakes on and we thought you
know let's build an email list first of
25 000 people before we launch the book
and the key to the success of the book
which led to all kinds of other success
and other things i really believe was
that when it came out and when we did
that launch it was that we had built
that email list where we had that
ability to communicate directly to say
hey we've been adding value we've been
showing up for our people but hey we got
this thing out that will add even more
value check it out and then of course we
were able to rank and keep it going
consistent all because of having an
email list and a lot of times like you
said creators entrepreneurs business
owners could be very vulnerable if they
haven't invested in this completely and
great job you guys setting that up i
think you know i have a lot of people
come to me to write and launch books too
building an email list up front before
or even as you are writing the book is
an amazing strategy you might not even
know exactly what you want to create but
you can bring people in on the journey
that in and of itself is interesting
enough to follow along and you get to
send little personal messages about your
updates of whatever it is that you're
creating then by the time this thing
comes out i mean they're invested
because they've been involved this whole
time
and that's cool thing about email you
would mention 25 000 which i think is
great i worry about people listening and
going like oh i could never get to that
level right and i think you have to also
realize that even if you had
10 people on your email list those are
10
human beings in this world who've said i
want to learn more from you please help
or i'm interested in what you have to
say
and then you can communicate with them
and ask them what they might need help
with thus reducing the idea that you
have to guess in terms of what you want
to do
and validate the ideas that you want to
pursue before you actually spend that
time and money to put into it in
celebration of the launch of this brand
new podcast we're giving away two
tickets to our annual conference grow
with video live a 1500 value all you
have to do to enter is make sure you
subscribe leave us a review on apple
podcast and then take a screenshot of
your review and go to
thinkmarketingshow.com
for the rest of the details yeah so
powerful well tip number one uh that you
have for us is if you're going to build
an email list do not just put up a page
and hope people sign up but give a
people a
reason to subscribe what do you mean by
that nobody wakes up in the morning and
says oh my gosh i can't wait to
subscribe to more email list today i
mean people don't want more emails so
you need to kind of let people know
well why should they subscribe what are
they going to get on the other end now
one trick that a lot of people use is to
give something away for free to sort of
help people who are on the fence to like
want to subscribe and there there are
hundreds of things you could offer that
don't require a lot of time when i first
started building an email list in 2010
i had created an ebook about how to
write an ebook because that was the
architecture guide that i kind of became
successful with it was an ebook and i
just was like hey i'm just going to show
you how to do this and it was like a
35-page document it took you know a good
couple months to put it together it was
it was a book and i gave it away for
free and that was high value for people
today however if you tell people hey
please subscribe to my list i'm going to
give you a 35-page document nobody wants
it anymore nobody has the time to do
that anymore so what i would recommend
is try to find what's the number one
simplest thing that you could do to
offer value to your audience and create
a lead magnet around that that's what
we're collecting leads here essentially
and a lead magnet is the thing that you
could offer in exchange so it could be
as simple as
i mean even like let's say you're doing
photography stuff your league magnet can
be the 20 20 guide to the top five
lenses under 200 dollars that you can
use on your sony or nikon cameras or
what have you canon uh and that guide of
itself if it's not public it becomes
something that people want if you know
that that's obviously relevant for them
and it could just simply be a page with
some images and some thoughts about it
but it has to be helpful but it doesn't
have to be huge right i think the
smaller the problem uh is sometimes the
better because it's just if you know
that's what they want right now they'll
subscribe for it but it's most important
that you continue the conversation after
which relates to some of the other tips
that i know we have going on but you
need to give people a reason to
subscribe or else
nobody sees an opt-in form and goes ooh
email
i want more email nobody nobody says
that yeah so true and the second tip is
the lead magnet kind of tip but what are
some ideas around
around best practices around lead
magnets and plus you help so many of
your students and your community maybe
even some cool lead magnet ideas and
different formats that could maybe
trigger what we could be giving away
free as entrepreneurs i got a bunch so i
i mentioned earlier the the list of
tools people love lists of tools because
we believe that when we get the tool
we're gonna be that much better right
i'm gonna get the great pro lens and i'm
gonna be this pro photographer right
away maybe but we love to see what those
tools are so that's number one number
two it could be a quick start guide so
maybe you teach a lot of people how to
do something like
maybe it's about a new camera for
example and there's some really
interesting advanced things you could do
if you for example sean were to create a
quick start guide about a new canon
camera that came out and gave that away
as a lead magnet now you're getting
email subscribers and now you also know
what they're up to they just bought this
camera now you could follow up with them
later about hey guys i know you have
this camera you can just send emails
just those people alone and go i have
these other things that will help you
too and that's so powerful because your
lead magnet does actually kind of
describe to you
what they're interested in if you do it
well exactly you know exactly who you're
talking to because they raise their hand
for that thing so a quick start guide is
great a checklist if you
and this is a specialized kind of lead
magnet where it can be related to a
specific video or blog post or podcast
episode that you come out with so let's
say for example you're doing a podcast
episode and it's like you know 20 tips
to
use facebook ads to you know sell more
of your product well in that episode you
can go oh and by the way go to this page
here and you can download my free
checklist it has all the things i
mentioned all in one spot for you and
you can use that to help guide you
through this process that's super
helpful a checklist you could also offer
the first chapter of your book as a lead
magnet which could then lead people to
get excited about it to then download
and purchase the rest of your book uh
you could offer a free video or an
exclusive podcast interview that you've
done that's kind of hidden or replay to
a webinar or anything of value that you
think would be helpful for your audience
that you're building
uh
would work and so i mean and this works
in any niche if you were doing sales you
might do you could do some scripts maybe
some powerful five opening script lines
if you were doing uh maybe i've i know
people in our community have done like
meditation they'll do an audio file
that's maybe gonna work on your mindset
or or something that's motivational or
educational uh it could be a short video
or some kind of a video that again
you're you're you're saying it should be
a quick win
quick win for sure because
that way they can see that there is
actual real value that's coming i mean
if it takes
40 days to get through the thing they're
never going to get to the point where
they go oh okay yeah okay
this guy's got it no if you could do
that in five to ten minutes
i mean they're going to continue to open
those emails they're going to come back
they're going to subscribe they're going
to your channel and they're going to
they're going to become super fans at
some point perhaps and you could create
this i mean i guess you could go to
google docs and export it as a pdf or
maybe use a powerpoint or a keynote and
export it like just pretty easy to
create those would be some pdf downloads
um you could record an audio file with
audacity like figuring out how to
actually create these right i mean it
could be an unlisted video on youtube
that's just for the people who subscribe
for example so after they subscribe they
get the follow-up email says hey thanks
click here to watch the video for what
you asked for and just deliver it to
them right away and they almost kind of
feel special getting something that not
everybody else has and then something
you could do at the end of the lead
magnet at the end of that video at the
end of wherever and just say hey if you
want to help share this if you think
this is valuable and you want to share
it
share this link and the link doesn't go
to that lead magnet it goes to the place
where they where somebody else can go
get that lead magnet now perpetually
growing your email list exactly super
powerful well that brings us to tip
number three which now that you've
created this free thing to give away
you want to set up a landing page talk
about that so a landing page is a page
on the web whether you host it or your
email service provider hosts it that
literally has nothing else to do when a
person lands on that page other than
subscribe to get the thing or leave
too often a lot of people who have
websites will
mention their free gift or or subscribe
here
but then there's like a hundred other
things you could do on that page you
could check the about page you could go
on the footer you could see this ad and
there's so many distractions this is in
in internet marketer terms called a
squeeze page i don't like that term
because i don't want to squeeze anybody
sure but really what we're doing here is
we're taking
traffic from somewhere
we're putting it onto this page we're
squeezing them to just do one action and
one action only you get the thing and
what's cool about this is they go there
and you can have an image of it or if
it's a digital product a digital
representation of it you could have
testimonials about people who've used
this free thing you could have a video
promoting it whatever you want to do
like you would want to sell it as if it
was a real product but it's freed it's
valuable and that's going to help you
increase your conversion rates yeah and
it could seem overwhelming you might say
well that sounds technical that seems
tough but setting up a landing page
especially in 2020 and beyond um has
really been easier than ever so easy oh
i wish we were this easy when i started
sure there's a lot of free software now
we use kind of in our whole world we use
kajabi which is a whole bunch of things
it's kind of the all-in-one that's where
our courses and landing pages i remember
when i started i use mailchimp with a
free account and i did a very simple
landing page up to a certain number of
email subscribers it was free to even
run the account and uh but there's some
other tools you like as well yeah i mean
full disclosure i uh
use and am an affiliate for convertkit
and i'm also an advisor for the company
because i love it so much and they help
a lot of beginners so if you're not
quite at kajabi level yet which would be
a great thing to lead into at some point
uh convertkit could be great and they
have a free plan as well so it doesn't
really matter they all do the same
things although there's reasons why i
love convertkit more than others but the
truth is you got to get started you got
to build your list and a lot of these
tools allow you to just create a single
page you don't even need a website yet
you can actually have a landing page
created and hosted by these companies
and then just you know feed that link
you can pay you can post a link to that
landing page in the bio of your socials
in your descriptions in youtube at the
bottom of your email signatures whenever
you send an email and you can just like
lightly drive people there and you'll
start to see your email subscriber base
grow and again reminder these are real
human beings that are now interested
that you could follow up with
communicate with and turn into something
amazing man that's so powerful and if
you happen to be watching this on
youtube of course we always summarize
some of our best resources and all the
show notes in the youtube description if
you're listening on audio check out the
show notes and we'll recommend some of
these tools uh so you can get started
whether you just want to jump in at a
free level or you want to scale up with
something powerful like convertkit as
pat was talking about i also love the
fact that once this is set up you really
now are in business and this can make
social media even more fun meaning it
could be an instagram story where you
might you know be showing behind the
scenes doing a lot of different things
but you might say hey by the way if you
didn't know i've got a free checklist on
whatever it is the problem you solve and
you could just swipe up or if you don't
have that feature click the link in my
bio or go to a
a forwarding url that's one of the
things we do a lot is we use a lot of
forwarding urls typically those landing
pages created by uh whatever software
are super long and maybe hard to
communicate and so if you had a blog you
might say
blog name forward slash whatever we a
lot of times we'll say like think
masterclass.com that goes to a webinar
which is a little bit longer you just
bought the domain but we just bought the
domain and we forwarded it really easy
and um godaddy we have
viralvideochecklist.com
and if you want to see an example you
could go to viralvideochecklist.com
what you'll see there
is a kajabi page and we just bought that
url on godaddy and redirected that easy
to create page in the software so if you
have like a really well performing lead
magnet like it's worth doing that for
sure because then
when you're on an interview audio or
video just super easy to drop that in
easy for a person to remember and and
plug into their computer the cool thing
about this like there's different kinds
of emails you can send so after you
bring people on this list right there's
a couple things you can do there's
broadcast emails which are real-time
emails you like
write an email and then it gets sent to
everybody it's pretty self-explanatory
but the other powerful thing about these
email service providers that we're
talking about which is the big
differentiator between just like
manually writing down emails and sending
them one by one which would eventually
just drive you nuts is something called
the autoresponder sequence and these are
emails imagine that you write ahead of
time so that if a person subscribes they
go through the sequence
of emails you've already written over
time so they get email number one on day
one they might get the next email a week
after the next email a week after that
and now you're sort of like
automatically
nurturing and providing value to this
audience some of these emails could be
you know include affiliate links to
things some of them could be to your
program after you know four weeks it's
just
you can write them once and they
continue to work for you and then the
next time you send a broadcast it's more
likely where there's something sort of
real time that needs to happen they're
going to be more likely to open the
email because they've opened all the
other ones and have gotten value from it
that's amazing and pat what is your
longest auto responder sequence that
so the longest one i ever had was 52
emails yeah one every week so it was a
year long it was a year long but
we've gotten a little bit more
sophisticated with our email such that
a person's in that year-long sequence
but if we see that they clicked on
something that is related to podcasting
for example we take them off that list
and we put them in a podcast sequence
that was pre-written so that we can sort
of warm them up about the idea of
starting a show overcome all the
objections again these are emails that
are already pre-written
and then sell them into a course perhaps
and your software is doing that
dynamically dynamically yeah it's
hands-off so
i can spend more time on social and
actually communicate with people i can
spend more time at conferences like i'm
not in the weeds anymore because i've
already built out the sequences so
powerful it's not easy but it's worth it
and especially when you have some of
these tips and strategies you can go
further faster and once you put in the
work then this is working for you and
that is the power of an email list well
that gets us to number four uh and that
is consistency and
messaging so now people are signing up
because you gave them something free you
figured out how to get them on your
email list and now they may just be on
the list so you can set broadcast so
maybe you're writing one a week or maybe
you've written a four week sequence or
four days in a row but what you're
actually saying in these emails pat
what's needed with our messaging uh when
it comes to these you need to speak the
same language that your target audience
resonates with so before you even build
an email list i think it would be really
important for you to do some research
about
not just the problems the pains the
interests of your target audience but
how did they describe them it was jay
abraham who said if you can define the
problem better than your target customer
they'll automatically assume you have a
solution so one thing for example i do
is i have
some lead magnets that are specific to
people who are just starting a business
like they i know that they don't have a
business or else they wouldn't have
downloaded this thing so that tells me
that they're brand new they've never so
they don't need the advanced seo guy
they don't need any of this stuff that's
probably going to make them feel
overwhelmed just beginner stuff
but what i do is in the first email that
i send back to them like it's already
pre-written
the subject line is welcome future
entrepreneur right so i'm like playing
on the idea that oh they're starting a
business right so that's kind of what
they aspire to but in that email i start
off by saying
hey really quick do any of these
following items
resonate with you and it's a bullet
point list of literally every struggle
that i know a beginner entrepreneur has
i don't know if my id is good enough i'm
afraid i'm going to waste my time and
money i think my friends and family are
going to think i'm crazy i have a secure
job but i don't want to leave it like
what do i do
so guess what's happening a person who
just subscribed to an email
list that i have because i got something
for free they get that message
they're essentially nodding their head
their entire time they read that and
they're telling themselves this guy
knows where i am he must
know where i can go
right and and it only and i've literally
gotten people to reply to that email and
go i feel like you're in my head like
how did you know or i can't wait to
learn from you thank you so much you i
feel like i finally found my person
right so really understanding the
language that your target audience uses
and just literally giving it back to
them which is which is why you can be
really sort of ninja with some of your
emails like one of my first emails that
i have in my autoresponder sequence
which you all should have it too should
be
the subject line would be like real
quick uh question for you and then in
the email it says hey can you reply to
this email and let me know what your
number one biggest challenges related to
you know starting a business or you know
whatever swimming whatever your niche is
training your dog exactly so now you're
actually going to get replies back
of your target audience telling you what
they want from you and what your next
video can be about what your next lead
magnet can be about what your course can
be about but you also need to you can
literally just copy and paste those
answers and and kind of extrapolate the
same language back to them so that
somebody else knew who comes in can go
oh my gosh like
did i find my people man you know that's
so powerful and really your business can
be lit on fire when you have a market
message match
and so if they're sending you what's
your biggest challenge with losing
weight or gaining muscle what's your
biggest challenge and now they're saying
well this is where i'm stuck and you may
have not known that so may give you an
idea but you might not have known the
way they're communicating that in the
actual language they're using yeah right
right and then in in the advanced parts
of your email list later on down the
road you can go oh here are the people
who said when they're you know
interested in fitness they're actually
interested in nutrition here are the
people who actually want to run their
first marathon here are the people who
want to do weight loss you know weight
loss
three different crowds but all in the
same niche so now you can kind of create
your buckets and find you know what are
the specialized messages within your
overall market and now i can send you
know to the weight loss people here the
programs i use here's my favorite coach
or who what have you people who are
interested in nutrition like hey check
out this thing that you could order to
get food sent to your home like you know
i can now
have have
specific homogeneous groups that each
get specific messages that's a little
bit more advanced and a little bit later
but this is the power it could be done
automatically yes right i could just set
these things up ahead of time and it's
working for me and literally dollars on
autopilot at some point man who would
have thought that we'd be getting
excited about building our email list
and these tips are so valuable pat thank
you we have a fifth tip coming up in
just a second but just want to ask you
that if you've been getting value and
you've been enjoying the think marketing
podcast in this episode definitely like
rate and subscribe so you don't miss an
episode i mean if you leave a review on
itunes that would mean the world to us
and then also if you haven't got your
tickets yet for growth video live
growthvideolive.com
pat flynn is one of our amazing speakers
this year and uh there's a whole great
lineup of guest speakers it's the number
one video conference for entrepreneurs
and so to learn more about that go to
growethvideolive.com
pat the fifth tip now as we are landing
the plane is that once people are on
your email list and even now that we're
thinking about our messaging and
speaking their language you want to make
sure that you're actually communicating
and that you're not just selling and i
think about this one of the worst things
i remember early on when i learned about
the power of an email list i started
growing one and i put together a landing
page i was using get response back in
those days
and even a free account put together a
landing page people started signing up
but
i wasn't sending them anything
i was just letting the emails collect
and maybe once every six months which
was not very effective and so not only
is there maybe some consistency but uh
like how often we should be
communicating and the fact that it was
also every six months i might have been
like oh here by the way now i have
something for you to buy and i have been
talking to him in the meantime yeah i
mean imagine in real life somebody who
you hadn't seen in a while come up to
you and go hey dude sean good to see you
you want to buy my tupperware it's like
it doesn't it's not going to come off
very well so you definitely want to be
consistent it doesn't mean you have to
send an email every day
in fact every day unless it's shared up
front it's quite often uh you know once
a week even every other week or even
once a month at least just staying on
top of mind for people is what's key and
delivering value so that when you do
have an ask it doesn't come out of
nowhere and so a person might feel the
need to you know transact because you've
gotten they've already gotten a lot of
value from you um so yeah staying
consistent is important communicating
but
communication in a sense of just
not having it be a one-way conversation
every time you know we touched on this a
little bit about the idea of you know
actually asking for a reply
like make that a thing where and i you
know i i share this tip with a lot of
people they're like no pat i don't want
people to reply to my email like that's
going to be too much work it's going to
be too much work for you to know exactly
what your audience wants and like we do
most of the work trying to figure that
out so make it easy and it also helps
with getting through again in the future
to them because if a person replies to
the email then that basically tells
gmail or yahoo or hotmail or whatever
their client is that oh this person's
like real i'm going to make sure all the
emails show up in the primary tab or
what have you later on so it helps for
that reason too and your deliverability
but
there's other kinds of emails you can
use to communicate um
for example hey tell us about your
experience with our brands so far is
there anything else we could do to
improve
uh
asking questions like hey we're thinking
of coming up with these three different
products which one of these would be
most relevant to you so now you're just
collecting data at the same time people
feel great because they're getting
actually permission to reply which is
very unusual and no it might not be
scalable
at all
but not everything has to be scalable
there's a lot of bits and pieces that
you can automate but communication
in this kind of senses shouldn't be
but you can get really you can have it
feel very very personal even on
autopilot with all with a lot of these
tagging and segmentation and automation
rules that can be popped in there well
man pat so much good stuff and obviously
they're except this is something you
grow into i mean now you've been
probably learning about email marketing
probably becoming a better writer over
years
studying kind of copywriting the art of
writing marketing copy and even just
writing in general as an author yourself
and and what's some encouragement there
for those that maybe are overwhelmed to
like oh man i'm looking at a blank page
start with the
service that you're offering for others
what do they really need help with and
just
as you're writing as you're doing your
work just think about that person on the
other end that always guides me
um and then if you are just struggling
in that cursors like on the screen
basically telling you you
can't right you can't right like that's
what i feel like it's saying to me right
i get off of the screen i don't try to
find it i go to talk to somebody about
it because when i talk to somebody about
it i don't have that cursor in my head
you just talk and you listen you have a
conversation and then usually when you
come back after a conversation even if
it's on social media uh usually you have
a better head space to get going so
powerful pat flynn if people want to
connect with you what are some of the
resources you have and where can they
connect with you online and follow up
with you so pat flynn on youtube would
be a great place to go i know your
audience loves the youtubes uh but i'm
definitely a podcaster at heart and if
you're listening to this uh very quick
and easy to check out the smart passive
income podcast or just look up pat flynn
you'll find probably one of five of my
shows there
uh it's it's my passion um and then pat
flynn.com my new personal site that just
went up man i love it and i'm so excited
that you're coming out to las vegas for
growth video live grateful for just your
legacy your influence in this space and
you know one of the reasons why you and
all of the other guest speakers we're so
excited about having you is because of
just your character your ethics and you
being just light in the world that it's
possible to do online business with
integrity absolutely and we see a lot
that's maybe not that vibe but that's
that's what we care about and we say
that look these are great tools with
they're not meant to abuse or manipulate
anybody but they're meant to actually
serve humanity make a difference in
people's lives and uh we need more
examples like you
that i think are are just showing us
kind of how to serve people and uh build
really transparent really powerful
businesses that you cannot just make a
great living from but also make a great
difference yeah you can sell and serve
at the same time you absolutely can love
that
all right the pat flynn interview i
can't believe the value he just dropped
in that interview all about email
marketing and you know email marketing
isn't some cool trendy thing it has been
the backbone of these businesses and i
am so excited that the think marketing
community just got that uh episode i
agree i mean there's really nothing
really to even re-emphasize about that
it's all in there i mean that was like a
real step-by-step of really how to get
started with email marketing and of
course so many resources in the show
notes if you want to take action on that
but i think my biggest takeaway from pat
is just who he is i have had the uh
fortunate uh you know
opportunity to get to know him over the
last few years and we've developed a
friendship and man he's just really one
of the good guys you know in the kind of
internet marketing online space there's
so many people that really are kind of
shady you can tell like they're they're
in it for themselves or they're really
not doing business with integrity or
their values are just kind of maybe more
selfish and directed on a lot of those
things but what i love about pat flynn
is that he's building an online business
with integrity that he loves people that
he's an incredible family man
and uh that he also just adds tremendous
value and that
whatever you hear from him wherever you
hear he's always serving he's got a
heart of service a heart of helping and
that he also now has really built a
legacy because he's been around in this
industry for like really almost like a
decade or more
really teaching really helping people
and it's cool to see longevity legacy
man he's like one of our think marketing
podcasts family members i feel like and
uh that's another reason why by the way
that's like
what we hope to anybody we really bring
to our event or on the podcast kind of
goes through that filter at some level
and uh pat though man he is just one of
the good guys i can't rave enough about
him but anyways i'm pumped because he is
coming to grow a video live um he
teaches as an authority on so many
different things super fans his book you
know of course smart passive income
affiliate marketing podcasting even
youtube now so he's gonna be adding
tremendous value this year in las vegas
and so i'm pumped yeah i cannot wait to
sit in his session i mean i i just i
love every time pat teaches because he
just brings
so much clarity to all of the topics
that he covers and if you want to see
pat flynn live with us at growth video
live 2020 here in las vegas you can go
to
growethvideolive.com right now to see
our best deals and
all of the amazing speakers that we have
that will be here in september
all right tms
listeners it is time though to take
action you've got to take the
information we just learned and say
what's your next step do you already
have an email list and you need to
double down and make sure you're mailing
them consistently
and and really actually following
through and not just capturing that
email do you need to just get started
and actually pick a provider or build
something free to give away don't
overthink it done is better than perfect
punch fear in the face punch
procrastination
in the face and get started with email
marketing and remember what gets
scheduled gets done so put it on your
calendar when are you going to follow up
on the notes and the learnings that came
from this episode so that you can start
building your business and your income
faster with email marketing yeah and
while you're writing that down we just
want to give a shout out to one of our
listeners that left a review on the
podcast sean i love reading these
reviews it's amazing to see the
community that's being built here for
the think marketing show and today's
comes from e-a-o real estate they said
the best business marketing and media
podcast in the world i love your youtube
channel i try to consume all of your
content to further my business but
sometimes i'm in the car and i can't
watch your videos so the podcast is
perfect so i can get tips on furthering
my business with their marketing and
media tips
man i love it and if you have not yet
reviewed the think marketing podcast
we'd love it if you just took some time
to go to apple itunes apple podcast and
just leave a review and guess what you
can be entered to win two tickets to
grow a video live for free by simply
leaving a review there's a few simple
steps and they are all outlined at
thinkmarketingshow.com so if you go to
thinkmarketingshow.com we'll walk you
through exactly what to do then you'll
be entered to win and maybe featured in
one of our comments of the week yeah and
we'd love for you to be a part of the
community that we're building here for
the think marketing show all you need to
do is click that subscribe button if
you're watching right now on youtube or
if you're listening in the car just like
they were when you're parked you can go
ahead and subscribe on itunes spotify or
anywhere that you love to listen to
podcasts we appreciate you we want you
to know that we're here every single
week to help you go further faster and
we cannot wait to see you in the next
episode
pat flynn know what's in now we're gonna
get it in social media marketing world
now we're gonna do it then san diego do
it now up and up get it down
this is how it happens now pat flynn
every single day when we rock this every
single day when we drop hits
you gotta know that it's pat flynn
helping you with passive income
income if you gonna